hi everybody welcome to another Google
developers live my name is Josh Livni
i'm here with Ava I guess bout a bitch
today and we are going to be talking
about google maps and freebase so Ava
can you tell us a little bit about what
is freebase sure freebase is one of
those exciting projects we have in
Google it's a data set and the database
of well known facts like people places
businesses and so on and derived from
the web it's shaped as a graph so each
node in this graph represents a real
world and lighting for example a person
or a place and then the edges of that
graph are representing the relationships
between different objects it's free to
use so it can be matched up with other
API slack for example maps maps ap is to
create interesting applications all
right so we have put together a pretty
straightforward demo application and
let's take a quick look to see see what
that looks like we seem to have a map of
San Francisco here with a whole bunch of
custom icons what happens if you click
one of these ah it brings up this
beautiful card showing some details
about in this particular case the
neighborhood and if you look at the
icons there are different categories we
have this little categories drop down at
the top left and free base is full of
tons of different categories and
subcategories and all these linked
categories but we've just taken kind of
a random sampling of some of them so
when you take a look at the code you can
see how to make these types of queries
so go ahead and click maybe a couple of
more and here we go and you get the
general idea so we have here at Google
Maps API some queries to the freebase
API and then in addition there's really
beautiful little cards library which
displays them in a nice manner and all
of that if you look at the URL is up on
github we'll talk a little bit more
about that in a second that is a very
cool demo so it sounds like we are
querying freebase maybe we could go a
little bit more detail into how we
actually do that to get the location
data back out yeah exactly um actually
we're using two different api's from
freebase in this application the first
API is the Search API
allows us to take some geographical
boundaries and ask freebase what are
interesting objects located in that area
and then we're using a topic API that
allows us to query for some details
about particular object so that we can
bring up the decart I can show you how
it works with the code into tabs of the
Chrome browser now awesome so we're
going to be taking a look here at first
Search API alright show us what we got
so when the map loads on the on the page
we automatically issue a query for the
freebase API I pulled out the developer
console to show you the query you can
see that we're creating the freebase
version 1 and point of the API and if I
go into the details of that request I
can look up what parameters were sending
to the to the freebase in order to get
our our data we sent two parameters
filter and output filter is a very
specific one of coordinating freebase
you can check the documentation of how
to format your filters in
developers.googl come / freebase and
here you can see that I have two
constraints in my filter first I
constraint which type I want a query for
in this particular case I'm asking
freebase for filming locations from
given radius and the second part is the
radius and the latitude longitude params
of which area I want to query form there
are many more parents that are available
such as check out documentation and
formatter queries accordingly the second
part on the output and tells freebase to
return apart from all like generic data
about the objects also the geolocation
data this allows the Maps API later on
to take over that data and plot it on
the map right so without that last part
would get the results back but we
wouldn't know the latitude longitude
where to place them on the map exactly
that's the point of returning the
geolocation data okay and after the
Search API let's just take a quick look
at the details API this is the topics
API
I we issued this query any time the user
clicks on a given icon because we want
to get more data about the particular
object the URL is a free based version
one topic because we're acquiring about
topics topics are nodes or entities in
in freebase and then each topic is
identified by a unique identifier
usually they look something like m / and
numerical value so here you can see that
issue just a get query for topic / m /
ID and that brings me back and a very
rich response with all possible data
that freebase knows about the particular
object right now in the example card to
render only some of this data but the
possibilities are really endless yeah so
for example correct me if I'm wrong we
might have say the architect of this
particular high school and then because
it's a kind of a linked graph we could
click more information for the architect
and get all of the other buildings he
may have had a hand in to get those
results back and potentially put them on
a map exactly because it's a graph you
can add a lot of exploratory features
for your users yeah so we're really
excited about this and having developers
do I sort of more interesting things
hopefully following this free bass
freebase craft along and maybe putting
them on a map if you feel so inclined
there's tons of stuff and it's a it's a
really cool and robust API so hopefully
you guys check it out and how about this
code if you want to get started we put
that up on github right yes exactly you
can find it under the Google knowledge
part of github it's open source and free
to forward by anyone interested okay
there it is and you can click on the
link at the bottom to be taken directly
there if you don't want to go to github
/ google knowledge and please fork it
check it out add some features we look
forward to seeing lots of more sort of
mashups here with their freebase data
and thank you very much for watching see
you next week thanks so much